l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono fa vj e oggi siamo sulla
seconda parte di sé come la dico bene
questa cosa in inglese come il mio
english and skin la totale ragazzi vi
lascio al video leggi che stai fermo è
watch
ma quanto [ __ ] questa cosa cosa come
faccio ad andare avanti che faccio alzo
zero ma zio
datemi una mano tutti quanti ebri bari
fa chi sa cos'è guan direction adesso
fate come me quattro uomini a passo
svelto andarono timbuctu quattro uomini
a passo svelto chi li vede più non
morita che vi state simpatici bene
meraviglioso meraviglioso sto gioco mi
chiami limbo e confrontare una cacata è
stupendo lo strato rando e veramente
incredibile morto di ogni volta che si
spacca le ginocchia così mica m'imprendo
male tra file alzarlo zio bravo fratello
vai giù a e l'alba mi piace il sole che
figata
non sto ben capendo dove sto andando ma
vabbè cos'è uno stadio fermi che
facciamo michael jackson 2.0 che caso
della fila del macdrive per me è un
cheeseburger e ragazzi grazie anno con
la il camion di prima a trasportavano
gente che volevano trasformare in zombie
per il videoclip di michael jackson non
ho ben capito perché ci sono questi
specie di caschi che controlla la gente
però cosa c'è di fuori cosa vedi 6sicuro
vai sennò amen
io scavalco e da un'ora e mezza che
scavalco cose ragazzino ancora i pulcini
nono domandatemi servite mi servono
quelli miss e qualsiasi cosa devono fare
mi servono sale la scala posso rico
mandare gli zombie michiara fantastico
[Musica]
e che cazzo ne fa mi serve come
piattaforma capito quindi devo saltare
due vado mi fido mi butto
no non mi fido non mi fido la mi fido
scherzavo
adesso sei morto però c'era tipo una
botola più avanti forse salto più avanti
tipo così tanta sfiga in una sola
persona
ecco dovrebbe essere a posto perfetto no
non ce ne si cela rotaia che passa pure
il treno quindi ti schiacciano pure meno
che io non debba tipo a ma che idiota in
carica un deficiente vai zio salta
perfetto mi piace ho fatto hamas o no
ora e 40 minuti per arrivare qua minchia
incredibile ce l'ho fatta ho trovato una
cassaforte che d'altro non so con quale
criterio rimanga in piedi questo coso di
legno adesso la spingo così crolla al
pavimento di sotto e voilà non ho capito
a cosa serva cazzo sono morto
ma dai ma che sfiga avevo devo togliermi
prima che caschi o che ho capito vai vai
a veloce race ok adesso torno indietro e
vado di giu sembra stupido ragazzi ma
col fatto che devi andare avanti
indietro e basta è un po un casino ha
forse sono gli zombie ragazzi di voti
può entrare così perfetto vai
mi chiamo capito devo farli andare
insieme nei cosi nelle piattaforme ed è
veramente un po un bordello questo gioco
perché non ci arrivi subito le cose sono
io che sono scemo anzi sicuramente sono
anch'io che sono scemo però di qua
ragazzi per forza devo capire dove
andare quando ero schiantato prima che
tra ero già arrivato a sto punto se solo
avessi la resistenza di caduta di
superman a quest'ora eravamo più avanti
zio a la madonna che scala dovrebbe
essere la fine della fabbrica o
qualsiasi cosa sia perché ancora non ho
capito dove siamo fatto mi devo buttare
su un altro camion di porci o qualcosa
del genere e tipo mirror's edge ragazzi
devo aggrapparmi al ci sono degli zombie
sotto tra l'altro che culo c'è buco del
culo tratto c'è un tizio che gli sta
guardando quello non è assolutamente uno
zombie sicuro secondo me ragazzi la fine
di questo gioco d'azzardo a dirlo
libererò tutti quanti gli zombie non so
come mai ciò questa idea però no no no
no mica stavo cadendo vai vai veloce
piano piano lo sapevo sono vivo salta
veloce prima che crolli perfetto teatro
prima o poi diventerà giorno pieno
perché sono dio che lo stanno facendo
andiamo a scovarne casa facendo questi
due stanno andando provate una volta a
mettervi fuori da una scuola e guardare
la gente che entra gli studenti sono
tutti così io dovrei riuscire ragazzi mi
date una mano per favore aprì la porta
che non si apre grazie no niente ce l'ho
fatta grazie opposto che sono stronzo io
che cazzo perché c'è sto tizio che alle
convulsioni cos'è sta roba ma attivato
con la macchina lì a cosa serve
ma cosa sono attivate io come fa essere
contro di me allora [ __ ]
all'attivo ma perché devo attivare una
macchina che mi uccide ma andate a
cagare
non l'ho capita sta cosa ci aveva le
convulsioni perché è attaccato al
l'elettricità o che ho capito quindi sta
macchina qua tramortisce tutti quanto me
ne può fregare a ok pro cales ho capito
quindi quella roba lì attiva la corrente
di tutto l'edificio quindi io posso
usare l'ascensore ma allo stesso tempo
si attivano sti cosi e cielo nel culo
cielo nel culo tipo il maiale ragazzi
quindi dovevo fare così e poi come
faccio dietro la colonna veloce mica
solid snake ragazzi solid snake veloce
come un deficiente madonna che culo ho
avuto un cul incredibile
non solo ma fatta non beccarmi va bene
va bene
non facciamoci domande vai vai apri apri
apri apri piano perfetto tanto dovunque
io stia andando ci sono sempre comunque
gli zombie quindi stiamo andando
esattamente nella loro direzione
fantastico questa si rompe si rompe lo
so che si rompe non si è rotta che come
mi sta andando veramente troppo di culo
perché io parlo e non sto zitto perchè
perchè non i videogiochi ancora non ho
capito
mi scusi non volevo faccio finta di
essere uno zombie e cammino
veramente non ci credo l'ha fatta
davvero se ne è accorto che non sono uno
zombie perché io camminavo malissimo
devo camminare come uno zombie perché
sennò mi mi scoprono nomi che un casino
quanto difficile ma guarda anche qualcun
altro caso solo me bellissimo st parte
geniale e geniale ragazzi della cosa più
bella è difficilissima perché se sbaglio
un secondo e qua non vedo quindi fa che
continui a camminare tanto sono tutto
sto cosa fa quello salta e stupido
quella è tutta gente non zombie quindi
sono i cattivi
sono cascati ci sono cascati non lo
saltare mi è venuto in mente all'ultimo
che dovevo saltare non so come anche
loro non si sono accorti che sono uno
zombie però è strano perché io sono la
maglietta rossa in teoria dovrebbero
accorgersi che c'è qualcosa che non va
vabbè ci sono anche dei bambini tra di
loro ma cos'è sta roba stanno
schiavizzando vabbè ma senti ma che
cazzo da fare o giocare a just dance
cioè non ho capito girati e ritardissimo
va bene va bene sono i problemi o largo
capiranno che lago ragazzi capiranno
ok ma perché tra tutti quelli che ci
sono delle controllare solo me quello
che nervi a posto
ok ok toriano mi sta controllando più
nessuno però non mi azzardo a cambiare
conosce altra gente perfetto c'è pure un
cane rabbioso ma qual è il problema
zitto testa di cane sei un bastardo e
non di razza ma cosa vuole a cosa vuoi
da me va bene tutto il sacco
la prima volta che provo odio verso un
animale forte è tanto se ne accorge che
sono uno che non va bene
corri corri corri corri
salta c6 per uno strapiombo quando c'è
un cane di segue non so perché
salve non mi farete nel male è vero sono
buono io anno a questi sono zombie ok
c'è sempre il cane di prima vai veloce
però ce l'ho ce l'ho
porca eva da casa ragazzi questa era la
seconda parte di inside continuerà nel
prossimo episodio mi piace questa cosa
di lasciare gli episodi a metà così la
gente si incazza che vuole vedere il suo
in seguito però io sono stronzo david è
piaciuto ma se il tracciato il commento
mi piace a capire le due comunità una
descrizione insorti si schieri civile
diavolo può subito e da ragazzi